[Music]
I go back to December
[Applause]
as Taylor Swift gets ready to release
speak now Taylor's version I would
always like to keep people on their toes
in that regard her ex Taylor Lautner
doesn't seem bothered well the album is
called speak now even though Back to
December one of the 2010 album songs is
about their breakup it's a very
autobiographical album and you know
sometimes there's stories about things
I've gone through there are a lot of
different things that have happened in
the last two years that have inspired
the concept of this album on Tuesday the
twilightstar Tells today.com he's not
worried about the swifties coming for
him Lautner says yeah I feel safe and I
think it's a great album you gave me
roses
Lautner's wife who's also named Taylor
agrees calling speak now one of the best
albums of all time music has helped me
so much in just getting through life and
that's one of the things I'm very
thankful to have discovered songwriting
meanwhile Lautner shows support for
another one of Swift's exes quote
praying for John yeah and name jokes
they're funny of course that would be
John Mayer Who was 32 when he dated 19
year old Swift and that's usually when I
write a song about it
seems to
be played by your Dark Twisted games
[Music]
yeah with the lyrics like those it's no
secret that Dear John was inspired by
her romance with mayor who at the time
told Rolling Stone he was humiliated by
the song
[Music]
the singer added it was a really lousy
thing for Swift to do
you gotta be so mean
but back to Taylor Lautner who's clearly
not afraid to look back on his time with
swift probably should have said
something the actor on his podcast The
Squeeze back in February I'm really
happy for you I'll let you finish
reflecting on his role in Kanye West's
Infamous VMAs moment I think people try
things on the VMAs they would never try
anywhere else but Beyonce had one of the
best videos of all time
I can barely hear it I can't see them
I'm just assuming that this whole thing
was a practice and rehearse skit yeah
because why else would Kanye West be
jumping up on the stage interrupting
Taylor Swift it just didn't make sense I
don't know him and I don't want to start
anything because I just you know I had a
great night tonight I've been getting so
many text messages
it's been really nice so I've had a
really really fun night it's been
interesting definitely it's definitely
been an interesting night what should
also be an interesting night when speak
now Taylor's version drops July 7th
[Music]